definitely will continue because it's
kind of part of my personality if you
like so I'm still attracted hearing
discoveries seeing things from a
different angle and yes I think it's
kind of I cannot I should I put it I
can't commit myself now but after I got
a prize I felt hmmm maybe at some point
I have to think about something else
open textbooks again and check out what
what else is there that people believe
and has been repeated many times many
times many times and everyone believes
it and and maybe it's not the end of it
or maybe something important has been
missed out I think it's very interesting
to see how science works this in
retrospect I didn't expect it honestly a
lot of it is perception I couldn't have
imagined that so sometimes people and
scientists perceive things in the wrong
way and just taking a different angle
and explaining things we're sorting out
things from a different angle all of a
sudden can open new aspects that that
you were totally unanticipated and this
is so important I think it's important
to to go back again say okay now we have
this phenomenon we have this thing but
we have to take a different angle C
maybe it's a different way of looking at
it still it has to be a valid one no
doubt but but taking a different angle
is so important i think the breaking of
the diffraction barrier is a fantastic
example because as i said the problem
was that people thought scientists
thought you have to distinguish features
so speak by the focusing of light the
phenomenon of focusing of light and
because it cannot focus light any better
than a certain diameter you cannot do it
but the breaking of the diffraction very
happened because i went back said oh but
do we have it do we have to separate by
the focusing of light or can we separate
by the molecular states and once we
separate the molecular states the
focusing of light
doesn't matter or hardly matters and
this is so important to understand so
just taking a different angle all of a
sudden makes things look totally
differently